what's up taste buddies Tasties taste
buds it's jodarosa here from the taste
buds podcast bringing you a special
holiday announcement that we are taking
a short short break from the show two
weeks that's it we're taking two weeks
off the week of December 26th and the
week of January 2nd so we can mend and
rest and I can heal and we can
rejuvenate and recharge and come back
swinging in the New Year the second week
of January with brand new taste buds
episodes and guess what
somebody you love I think is going to be
coming back soon
do you know who I mean I think you know
who I be
[Music]
you just might be seated with it was
early January episode
I'm sick what do you want from me
anyway thank you thank you thank you as
we close out 2022. to everybody that has
supported this show thank you for the
likes thank you for the comments thank
you for the wonderful messages thank you
for the presents you said sometimes
that's above and beyond I can't even
wrap my head around it thank you for the
artwork again just amazing above and
beyond uh thank you for the reviews most
of them good most of them I the bad ones
you know maybe tune out instead of
leaving a star because you didn't like
the way the episode went anyway that's
neither here nor there let's keep it
positive
for the holidays thank you for
everything you have given us including
whatever this disease germ thing is that
you've given me
I appreciate all of you Sal appreciates
all of you pimp appreciates all of you
Venetia appreciates all of you we all
here at the no pressure Network
appreciate all you all of you and that
is coming to you from me jodarosa AKA
Chrissy chaos AKA Chrissy Christmas
times AKA Chris is a
Pig he's a pig DeStefano is a pig that's
right Krista Stefano is a pig but you
know what I know he appreciates you too
thank you thank you no press supporters
happy holidays and we will see you again
the week of January whatever the second
week in January is I don't have a
calendar in front of me all right let me
be I need to lay down now cake and he's
telling me that if I put it by
definition
if I put a little heat on toast it's no
longer bread a little heat on bread it's
no longer bread go back to whatever that
just said about the misconception of hot
bread it's not because that's how rules
work what is rules you want to talk
rules you lost the first season and you
have yet to do anything about it come up
with a punishment there has been 10
punishments [ __ ] I'm right here that's
[ __ ] and yes I will bring up
McDonald's in this episode oh no [ __ ]
just like how there was an episode when
all the boot-shaped McNuggets were the
dark meat and then they started mixing
dark and white meats and then all of a
sudden you're getting boot shaped white
Meats they did the same thing with
caramels in Russell Stover's box
you're defining a nuggetish chicken I
can't even wrap my mind about the words
coming out of your mouth oh listen to me
no no I don't like a chicken nugget it's
not chicken it doesn't matter okay he
wishes he worked at McDonald's he wishes
Ronald McDonald adopts him he he he he
McDonald's is his Heaven it's time to
b-a-t-t-l-e buds Walden was one of the
big time Joe you gotta cover your mouth
I mean in normal life but in these times
you're just blowing it out into
everybody I'm sorry I went over that way
I got nervous that I was gonna
lie there was a lot going on I got it
right into the end no I just I didn't it
just there was no snot expel I got a
little nervous I got nervous that I
would take us through it when what
happened when did you get nervous at
what point just panicked that I was
going to sneeze your way so then I
turned and then I was going to cover my
and then I was like What if I get
something on my hand and I touched on my
and I was like but if you don't get
something on your hand that means
nobody's over there that's a clear but
but you didn't know if you want to get
something on your hands so rather you
get it on the carpet I I knew I wasn't
gonna get anything onto the car I don't
know I just panicked leave me alone
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this is how I reacted
and now it's a documentary winner
that's how hard he hit him right wow
hold on a second hold on you have so
much
you have so much respect for him
you [ __ ] [ __ ] okay yo if you're
done with that can I actually take the
straw out of it
it's really bad
yeah I hate it I have OCD I thought oh
with a straw thing yeah uh ideal for me
Joe it's a lay it sideways uh no no like
like not pointing at me or what you did
should I put this on here
yeah
like just not so it's not pointing at me
yes I didn't want to see it yeah oh
you're like like it's a fear of straws
uh or like a uneasiness with straws
that's true is this anything pointing at
me
really it has like a pointy Edge kind of
yeah wow okay okay interesting
please tell me you're taping this all
right
welcome back to The Taste Buds podcast
I'm glad you just got a glimpse of the
insanity
yeah
[Laughter]
he has a [ __ ] quite together when it
comes to the money that's right
he seems he seems to get the shooting
schedule's down fine that Daddy can deal
with it
when you have a certain amount of cash
that's what that's the [ __ ] that bothers
you
Hershey's white chocolate cookies and
cream that's on the regular shelf all
the time yeah yeah the regular that all
of these they just the only first of all
oh God sorry no no
crunch don't you
don't you oh the message the white
crunch version no what are you not well
this is this is It's BLT versus bacon
egg and cheese okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know all about it
how you feeling you think he's he's the
dead man walking away go over there
slunch away from me feel my head I'm not
sure I'm not gonna touch you that's
insane why would I touch you if you
might be sick I was leaned back he's got
a problem with that joke you don't want
me leaning forward yeah I met Tupac
huh I gotta tell you it is more fun this
way doing it just making you feel bad
about it what if you have coveted
I hope I do yeah I hope you do but I
hope you die I hope you guys and I won't
because I'm athletic yeah no you're not
yeah [ __ ] oh my God you ever see him
play Frisbee are you joking you don't
wanna yeah I work myself feel bad about
yourself do you think you cannot get
covered if you work out if you work out
you're less likely to have severe
symptoms Joe look at that body
that body babe
[Laughter]
I can eat two eclairs and be like hey I
had two eclairs all right it's dessert I
shouldn't eat dessert whatever I eat two
cannolis I want to throw myself off a
building
definitely
I go guilty
and he's correct he's really I mean what
is this
stop it I'm just saying stop stop
lofting these are counter arguments that
make you all the time had counter
arguments bro don't worry she said there
were great counter arguments well I'm
saying what he's saying I'm telling he's
dismantling your counter arguments I
have made these arguments saying his
count arguments are arguments I make two
all the time when we're battling and you
dismiss them dismiss them now
well you know each battle and its own I
take each battle in its own
you were like your last meal all we can
have is a pork chop I wouldn't I would
say no would you pick salmon as your
last meal 1 000 yeah
want salmon in my coffin over a pork
chop you would pick salmon as your last
meal if you had the it could pick
anything you wanted not even [ __ ]
close dude I tell you this I'd rather
eat a bat from China than a pork chop if
this is real soda what like pure
insanity
once contain the drug but much likely
less than the than a post claim how is
this even [ __ ] possible I never heard
of this
I can't believe you've never heard of
this before
it says here the first bottle of
Coca-Cola contained three grams of
cocaine
[Laughter]
wait I'm sorry Coca-Cola the soda that
they sold in stores two kids yeah had
cocaine in it yeah cocaine at one point
was not illegal in this country as far
as I know or it was at least in a
beverage or it was at least socially
acceptable don't forget it comes from
the cocoa plant it was much more pure it
was not you know what I mean it comes on
the cocoa plant yeah you're not you
weren't dealing with the [ __ ] you're
dealing with today I didn't I don't
really know much about cocaine I
realized uh Eric Clapton wrote a good
one about it it's not his song by the
way it's a cover okay yeah I also like I
didn't know remember that song I'm in
love with the Coco oh yeah I thought
that guy just liked a really nice cup of
cocoa oh yeah I I found out I found out
later that it meant cocaine I was like
remember the best food in the invention
of man is the staple ingredient to
anything anyone eats that says it's
delicious that's idiot go watch go watch
uh what's his name
Anthony Bourdain read his book he says
the reason anything tastes like anything
in every restaurant you've ever is
purely butter butter is the Cornerstone
from which all tastes come in food bread
bread fresh baked bread there is nothing
better than it warm fresh every single
restaurant begins with bread I'm a big
believer in the face start your days
with bread and butter toast on toast oh
come on
that's not that didn't just happen
stop it that's not even that's not even
what I'm talking about what I'm talking
about is a fine Mist that covers a lot
of ground in a little time I close I
kept almost everything shut I panicked
see like that so so see yeah that's what
it really really really looks like
I don't believe that she's spraying so
you understand but if you put it in a
real what they they have they filmed
them I don't believe that look at that
look at that he's wearing they dyed the
mist and he's wearing it under a black
light look at what's all over him that
is all over us right now it's not all
over us at worst case scenario it's all
in this area of carpet and nobody's ever
gonna eat off of that area of carpet and
it was an accident but I panicked but it
doesn't just go to the carpet it goes
it's just it's such a fine Mist that
goes into the air there's not listen man
listen uh sneezing or farting what would
you rather be done fart
I can't catch
yeah that's [ __ ] party well he just got
his pants on
his nose or his [ __ ] Joe it's a menu
[Music]
famine the microwave oven tensing now
that's a nice touch that's not that's
not what that is that's a nice touch
they bring out the whole tray for you
buy at the store that is not disposable
I guarantee you that's hard I guarantee
you that's okay that's hard too I think
it's a pen you think you're getting hard
ten I know you're out of your mind you
think they're bringing out foil that is
a disposable two dollar you buy it and
throw it away stop it stop it all right
but my point is I think it's a nice
touch stop it what you're doing is
you're buying the whole that's a nice
touch if you put that on the center of
your table at a dinner party I'd spit on
your table that's not true that's not
true at all at home we make lasagnas in
those tins are you nuts you don't serve
a lasagna in a tin like that yes you do
it you break that tin right at the
center of the table funeral reception
you're wrong you're wrong you take that
tin out of the oven you drop it right on
the table and you cut squares right out
of that tin prove me wrong please
how do you cooking casserole in a glass
casserole babe I put it in a glass
casserole I oil a glass casserole they
want us to eat but I think they're wrong
I mean that tastes like an Oreo so I
don't know what to say that because that
tastes good you know what I'll say to it
I'm taking another piece yeah I don't
like it you really don't like this I
actually this just made me say don't put
it on the list it tastes like an all
cream Oreo I don't like it it just
tastes like sugar but who's putting
salsa verde
on marshmallow and hazelnut it's a
little spice I gotta be honest right now
I don't like the attitude you have about
this
that's a great sandwich maybe you should
keep this keep the Secret Sandwich a
little more secret oh
[ __ ] your child your child I'm a child
speaking a child children are welcome
here at Joey roses I wouldn't expect you
to understand this sandwich
I'm completely intrigued
give me
well that was the jugular right there
that's a jugular stick around oh boy is
this what you guys do yeah
good idea for a show so Joe do you know
this about Joe Joe's uh from a suburb in
Philly yeah and next to his home he grew
up uh you know an only child yeah me too
and you did we talked about we didn't
talk about this but he had a ditch near
his home what it was
yeah yeah the the relate to me train
stops here he had a ditch near his home
and he used to go just alone and play in
the ditch and then he used to just sit
and he used to ruminate and pontificate
in the ditch as a child
I got lightheaded what yeah so he used
to just it's it's sad
he would just sit alone in a ditch yes I
feel like I'm gonna cry I know it's sad
but it's sweet and we knew it complete
when we wore a younger man's clothes but
last time we also learned from him and Q
that his adopted father used to spend
time in the ditch alone as well it was a
family affair oh I didn't know that some
of the taste buds fans know I used to
sit as a child and stare into it what
this is the ditch
this is the ditch this looks like when a
convicted murderer takes the police to
show them where they hit the body
no matter what happens every
time I love you all right
you know I'm gonna use that my parents
I wish my parents did that here we go
you have never had something you're not
with caramel in it that kicks it up the
way marshmallow kicks something
else
shooting out of his mouth as an enhancer
you cannot touch caramel because Marsh
there's no such thing as a marshmallow
drizzle caramel drizzle [ __ ] that's
fancy [ __ ]
on top of the sweet potatoes at
Thanksgiving I'm off full marshmallow
you dumb [ __ ] that's what I'm saying
right it's an enhancement no but not
like a caramel drizzle a caramel drizzle
a [ __ ] Chef you got [ __ ] Gordon
Ramsay
stand up so I can hear you when you're
talking out of your [ __ ] because it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] you look at this weekly
with this dumb piece of [ __ ] what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's all functioning idiot
does he hang his [ __ ] helmet at the
door before he walks in here because I
swear to God I [ __ ] what time does
your ride get here I can't [ __ ]
believe you put yourself through this
he's a [ __ ] I swear to God is he
battery operated he needs to be [ __ ]
rebooted he needs to be rebooted because
there's something [ __ ] wrong with
your dumb Friends Jesus Christ taste
buds like [ __ ] taste dud he's got
enough [ __ ] tasting nothing Jesus
Christ
hold on I'm sorry what were you saying
what I'm talking about because the pizza
one sucked balls Pizza
day with the crackers
disgusting Lunchables of course no
disgusting I mean a pepperoni a plane
disgusting from front to back
when I was a child
I liked him when I was a kid when I had
the palette of a baby
he's like when I was uh when my palette
was was developed enough to understand
the lunchroom
you back me no matter what let's take a
time out we have our own peanut butter
oh that's right you stupid [ __ ]
I have two peanut butters and a beer
what my face is on the label I mentioned
our peanut butter
by the way she hit us up again she wants
to do a new run and a new flavor so
shout out Saratoga peanut butter the
best peanut butter in the land babe I
for I have never mentioned our peanut
butter to our kitchen we got the no
brush pack you could buy the are you are
you insane
sandwiches with your own peanut butter
oh my God what a disgrace oh my gosh
look at this it's the third time you
knocked those cards off today he doesn't
like things on the floor
my couch in Abomination cut to the tape
of his [ __ ] couch it is the worst
couch I have ever seen in my entire life
my couch upstairs makes your couch look
like it's just a [ __ ] pile of dog
[ __ ] you have a red leather couch that
is trying to be modern it's so
uncomfortable it's not practical at all
it's ten times worse than my couch you
it looks like it's from a porn set it
looks like it's literally from a point
it's like a guy trying to be hip getting
red leather but it just doesn't go you
need you need an Archie Bunker that's
what you need an Archie Bunker type of
of of of recliner
a red leather guy who are you trying to
fool
it's starting to get salty you can fast
all you want your body will always suck
ready
okay it's time to get salty it's
starting to get salty it's starting to
get salty I [ __ ] actually hated your
stand-up hour
oh my God it hurts time to get salty
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty
stop thinking
period
great I just it's just too much okay
it's just too much I agree I'm tired of
discussing I'm tired of going over
everything I agree yes please okay give
it a rest okay nobody cares I agree
I agree Sound Advice okay
you're a hypocrite Pepsi good
oh my god look it up
so good dude it feels like a scab it's
so [ __ ] good it feels like a scab
I mean if you're saying it's not good
you're moronic
of course it's good
that's hard Romanian salami straight
from the [ __ ] motherland the only
thing that survived Nazi invasion was
this recipe for the salami try to go
French dip before I go corned beef
that's crazy you're nuts you're nuts
Frank you want to talk about a boring
sandwich I mean I like a French dish I
respect you Moxie because I think you're
gonna get [ __ ] canned here because I
think ham and cheese because you have a
you have a knack for picking the most
mainstream like big it was the it was it
was like when the two oh my God
together again
I know I can't
I can't turn 45
. no dude I know I know dude
I've been having we were going through
the crisis
is this what it is it is it's the
midlife it's the midlife
I can't believe I'm even saying that but
it is we're having the midlife I mean
we're halfway to 90.
now when's the last time you cried so
I've tried yesterday today something
like that
bro I had a cousin who was a Ronald
McDonald no he went to clown college I'm
seeing him this weekend in Phoenix what
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute okay time out couple things are
you wait wait wait I swear to God I feel
like if you go to clown college but then
you become Ronald McDonald you are a
failure because Ronald McDonald isn't
doing name a better clown that's that's
name Nick knew the boss clown of Ronald
McDonald this guy is AJ
yeah we just read about AJ you know AJ
yeah he just passed away like a week or
so ago
play the lotto we have to dedicate this
episode we had to what are the odds what
are the odds something's weird today
something
we've had we're having way too many
coincidences happen how do you know that
AJ died a week ago did you keep in touch
is there a newsletter is there an alumni
letter yeah there's a alumni face group
of all the former Ronalds oh my feedback
I need that this is as good as I had
hoped holy [ __ ] wait so then so then did
you have other clown friends that
weren't Ronald's that became Ronald's
with you and then you had Ronald friends
yes so like all walks of life became
Ronald's what's that magicians all
different walks of life could become
around so there's guys that were
magicians that became Ronald there were
guys like me that were like clowns that
became Ronald was there like Ronald
resentment when I leave the supermarket
with a watermelon I also feel like no
matter what I'm getting a great deal
it's a bargain buy which is not always
the best thing in the world you put out
into little balls you ever see them do
that yeah I love that too no character
whatever form you put [ __ ] into it [ __ ]
the reason is it first of all it looks
like a little cockroach no it doesn't
yes it does no it does when I was little
it took me a while to get used to eating
uh Raisin Bran because it looked like I
just had a bowl of cereal with a bunches
you can't sit that's one of the things I
hate about the watermelon fruit should
be a travelable meal fruit why fruit
should be able to be eaten on the go wow
fruit because because I said so where is
a raisin besides a cinnamon raisin piece
of
first fruit to permeate the breakfast
cereal the Cornerstone of Trail Mix the
first fruit to enter into the candy
Department don't you talk to me about
this go to the phones
going up against uh Walden was one of
the big time Joe you gotta cover your
mouth I mean in normal life but in these
times you're just blowing it out into
everybody in front of you sorry I went
over that way I got nervous that I was
gonna uh
there was a lot going on you just shot
it right into the air I just I didn't it
just there was no snot expel
I got a little nervous you don't know me
and you don't know my immune system I do
I know your immune system very well
actually I I'm not better than me yeah
he goes here he goes
it looks like you spit a loogie
oh my god oh that's gross
[Laughter]
all right let's get rolling and we did
such a real you look
insane
you can't [ __ ] this
let's get rolling guys
uh why in the show why am I why am I
already seeing Sal in a burger costume
what am I thinking of
fantasy too fancy now I see him all the
time
he turns into a burger
oh that's funny all right now
guys if you want to support the hey
SpongeBob subscribe to YouTube leave a
comment on iTunes rate US and follow us
on Spotify that's the best way you can
help us run away that's the no pressure
Network folks the no brush Network on
YouTube subscribe now
no matter what happens I love you no
matter what happens I love you no matter
what happens I love you all right I wish
my parents did that well we used to come
away from these sometimes and he was a
little scorned because we really get
heated yeah and he'd go home and he'd
carry it with him but I said it's for
entertainment Joe let it go you don't
carry a lot on that's why your shoulders
are gross
it's
little shoulders the ski slopes I know
straight down you know I thought about
getting shoulder implants at one point
what you didn't even watch Back To The
Future Three that's yes you watch it
half of it when it first came out
through it I didn't see anything it's so
bad it's not bad
I don't need to walk up to a pile of
[ __ ] and bury my nose in it to know it's
a pile of [ __ ] they do the thing yeah
but how many times has Star Wars are
like I got a bad feeling about this
party it's the same you stop it
[Music]
concept of time travel they made time
travel fun the DeLorean is like nothing
I've ever seen before DeLorean was my
like I it was like before I was into
women like I wanted a DeLorean uh they
said this they go we felt that in the
third movie it was time for Doc to have
a love interest why not shut up nobody
cares about weird doc having sex I
[ __ ] another thing I'd watch if I had
the ability
it's the worst thing that you could ever
buy and for your mouth
popcorn before you even say it caramel
popcorn your popcorn Cracker Jacks in
this corner here Cracker Jack's in an
episode you don't be [ __ ]
that's true that's also true uh baseball
oh
the question
for me marshmallow it's texture I don't
trust a marshmallow it's you don't know
the form it's had I don't know it's a
little bit like flesh yeah it is it's a
little flat all right and caramel it's
going to be stickiness it feels like you
know Willy Wonka's load
to me it's just amazing wait Queen
Elizabeth died choked on the werthers
that Jack Daniels is almost gone
um big sip
I can quit anytime
Joe Joe everything strawberry could do
banana can do better come here good luck
good luck getting into supermarket and
find me right right properly ripe
bananas nine times out of ten they're
over ripe or they're way under ripe it
is so hard to find right nobody buys
bananas on the day they need bananas I
want them for that week I don't feel
like waiting a week plantain
I could give a [ __ ] about the plantain a
banana is a berry welcome to my world
[ __ ]
I'm the Chiquita banana and I'm here to
say okay yeah it's good that's good can
I tropical my [ __ ] point you [ __ ]
go ahead without a split let's talk
strawberry on ice cream it's so good
dude
alcohol you're in a bar drinking you can
go man they did this in the old west
yeah the pioneers of this country the
people that conquered this country they
were drinking in a bar in the saloon in
their Town that's the history but weed's
got a better history because you got
Woodstock man you know wow what a
difference Woodstock made you guys were
just so great at Woodstock that's your
history with weed who needs the people
that conquered the frontier in this
country when you can be part of the
history of a bunch of hippies puking and
having sex with each other and they're
stinking dirty ass tents as some awful
band goes on and on on the stage Crosby
Stills and Nash whatever horseshit they
booked at that Festival oh God you know
what I mean so weed's better in that
sense wait what let me tell you
something right now if if there wasn't
Health implications to just literally
just throating bread and butter all the
time I would have bread and butter all
the time it is it is comforting
how does this it is crunchy it is
bread and butter falling out of your
obvious very strict Health richness
charcutie board is okay yeah you know
what it is it's too rich it's too rich
it's too much I don't want to eat I
don't want to eat nine different slices
of processed meat you don't know you're
such a dumb child I'm a dumb child
you're an old old crotchety man okay
well an old country man in his food
experience knows how to eat food
Triscuit is your food experience it's
Nabisco it's an island yeah yeah you got
food experience I like bread and butter
okay
goddamn three-year-old
well Ranch for me is the least best of
all the dips and all the salad dressings
I don't like the consistency I don't
really like the smell I'm not I'm not
exactly I've mentioned this before when
we talked about the battles I'm unclear
about what Ranch is I don't know what's
in ranch I don't know why it's called
Ranch I don't necessarily like the word
Ranch for a dip I kind of used to like
it in a Dorito but now I've eaten it so
much that I do not like it in a Dorito
if you put Doritos in front of me that
are cool ranch I will pass because I've
had enough with the ranch I know that
that's not true because I saw a video of
you when you were doing the tour with
Chris at Christmas time and you were
eating from a bag of ranch Doritos there
was three days they weren't traditional
ranch and it's all we had and I was
starving oh that is gross that's really
good Lester's Fixins ranch dressing soda
see this is what I'm saying that's out
of control that's out of control
foreign
I can't believe you got the balls to
come on here what you try to put the
chicken finger against the hot dog you
are insane yeah I think you're insane if
you go on a date and you order chicken
fingers she'll be like I'm never having
sex with this man
disagree more
she would share the chicken fingers
I'm gonna have sex
having sex if you order a hot dog you
know what else is a cute date move we're
in the Park oh want to get a hot dog
wouldn't it be fun to go to the hot dog
stand nobody on a date goes oh wanna go
get chicken fingers you're in the park
though you're in the park I can't do it
with this kid sometimes I can't do it
with this kid sometimes I can't deal
with this kid sometimes I can't do it
with this kid sometimes I've never had a
turkey club that was like this is lights
out good it's okay but it's I think it's
a lot of smoke and mirrors you can do
whatever you want it's not just one
sandwich it's it's multi-sama it's
modular yeah that's why it's great and
it always comes with fries fries So you
you're making little sandwiches you're
getting a little yeah it's a fun dishes
it's a nighttime classic that's America
look at that sandwich it almost has the
red white and blue it's like look at all
that everybody's representing
I didn't say that
picked it up you went forward in your
head Coca-Cola had cocaine in there so
that's a strike against Coca-Cola in my
book strike
Eight's a strike that they took it out
May 8th
I believe Pepsi tastes better you're out
of your mind I don't shut up you can
take your Santa Clauses you can take
your Clydesdales and you could take your
polar bears I got Michael Jackson
got Michael Jackson
[Music]
I'm gonna say to you just cause you get
loud doesn't mean that you're gonna
discredit the Pepsi challenge the Pepsi
challenge is well documented
changed their formula because they were
scared that they didn't taste as good as
Pepsi which tastes better
Pepsi in a country where presidential
elections can be stolen he's going to
believe that the production challenge is
real you're gonna believe that there's
hard on the Pepsi challenge
they would have seen me weeping
multiple times throughout the movie
throughout the Elvis movie throughout
the Elvis movie when the end of this
thing hit
I was crying so much that when the
lights came on for the credits I ran
like I had to go to the bathroom it was
[ __ ] I had to go into the bathroom
and finish crying because I didn't want
my parents to see me crying because I
was so embarrassed
I came out of the bathroom
I'm trying to like make it my eyes not
look red my mom was like oh my God I
loved it so much the ending I almost
start crying again I walk away
for two days after I got back whoa so
what was so emotional I'm gonna ruin the
ending for you got to see it okay well I
know he does
you foolish child
you foolish cheap joke child foolish
Hearts you just hear me you don't
deserve to hear the ending of this movie
Strike one is your egg strike two is
your cheese a bacon egg and cheese is
all Grease
it is all Greece it gives me a
stomachache dude bacon is so greasy man
bacon is on your sandwich I know that's
what I'm saying you need something to
lighten its load you serious in this
battle I want to but you just said
strike two is your cheese bro cheese
makes the world rotate on that sandwich
on that sandwich yes are you okay no my
back is killing me I know but you look
like there's a host of problems my back
is killing me look fans look what I'm
doing for all of you right now don't say
anything off The Beacon Theater together
yeah you you you you headlined The
Beacon Theater you headlined the
hometown it was sold out your whole
family was there a lot of friends were
there yes and I was very honored to be
on that show uh opening for you it was a
wonderful experience it was great I mean
I plugged it enough but thank you New
York City we sold out uh it was just a
just a a really really memorable night I
I I it was beautiful yeah yeah I mean I
just had a blast it was the crowd was
hyped tons of friends and family there
it was just like you know a home home
Township home field it was beautiful it
was beautiful and thank you by the way
uh
uh fans Sal fans taste buds fans uh for
coming down to Joey roses yes I went
down to Joey roses after the show it was
packed uh and it was everybody we could
come down from the show yeah it was
awesome and then on Sunday people were
coming through that's awesome it was
really really what a heartwarming
experience I was telling Christy D about
it I was like dude the cheers that Sal
got the cheers that I got the cheers to
pimp got
the um Q stuck his head out the cheers
that Q got sticking his head out the
cheers that Chris got what I did when I
told the story about Chris headlining
the beacon yeah like it I go do it it
just felt so much like it felt like we
were like a community and it's and it
was great and we didn't tell anyone you
were gonna be on the show oh yeah we
purposely kept that back because you
know once you got a little surprise to
everybody yeah that was fun that was fun
yeah and you got a nice you got a nice
pop babe I never got a pop like that in
my life really yeah that was the biggest
pop ever oh amazing they people cheered
for the sandwich shop
well Chris who's the greatest was was
was went on before me and Chris uh said
by the way is it John stun yeah it is
right okay he said uh he goes your next
comedian has the hottest sandwich shop
in New York City and everybody started
cheering and I was like this is so crazy
but watching you walk out and get the
reception you got seeing Pimp Get the
reception he got it was just it was just
awesome man it was really I was touched
I was floating for a while yes me too
guys I mean it was just like we do a lot
of shows you know we're on the road all
the time uh and uh you know sometimes
they just extra extra special that one
was crazy my grandma was there she's
like 90.
my niece yeah you did right yeah she was
cool yeah my niece she had so many
sandwiches she did yes they enjoyed them
very much my mom actually smuggled a
bunch out I know I was with your mom
walking out
uh uh that sounds like it's like gonna
be a mom joke
it wasn't I was with your mom we walked
out together just coincidentally and she
was like talking to me about how she was
smuggling sandwiches yeah she said to me
can you get me some sandwiches I'm like
just go get a plate put a bunch in them
cover them with another plate walk out
you're not stealing them I bought them
yeah thank you for buying sandwiches bro
yeah of course yeah
um but uh yeah I mean and my even my
like nieces and nephews might as little
as my two and a half and three and a
half year old niece and nephew were
there so like it was just one of those
things you know everybody was side stage
was everybody and it just was like that
night for us at least you know when
we're at a a landmark like that with all
of our friends and I just special and
you just feel the buzz by the way Q
something I feel the buzz in rare form I
got it on video on Instagram I call it a
little little bit of it I shot it he
helped me he helped me plug my Austin
dates I saw that
where did he what happened where was he
coming from nobody knows I heard he was
nice and lit up he was letting everyone
know he was lit up he was very vocal
about how drunk he was he was fun yeah
he was very fun he was very vocal about
what he drank which was I believe he
said six margaritas and two shots that
sounds like when you're in college yeah
you're like bro how many shots bro I did
I drank five beers and seven shots but I
don't know where he was or who he was
with he just kept saying an old friend I
don't know I don't know where he was I
think it was what he was referring to
kill as an old friend
Joe do you remember being side stage you
were having a moment looking at all the
people who performed there and then he
walked in and said they were all Pricks
yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah I was I
was
when Chris was on stage I was pacing
around because I was a little nervous
and he came up and chastised me at
length
for being nervous dad started saying
things like you want some you want some
advice I I've played the garden baby it
started doing that
and then uh and then started pointing to
the pictures of everybody backstage
saying that guy's a prick that guy's a
prick that guy's a prick it actually is
crazy the wall of the and I realize it's
pictures of everybody in the elevator I
signed the elevator which was the
coolest I forgot to do the elevator
thing the the one guy asked me I forgot
to do it you're insane dude I didn't
know it was that's what it was every one
of those photos on the wall those
portraits are of the band or the person
in the elevator
and uh i s yeah I signed it and took my
elevator shot he asked me because I was
about to go on and he goes you want to
do it after and I go yeah yeah let me
just go on first and then I didn't even
know what the significance of it was he
was he just said you want to take a
picture sign on the wall you know I
didn't know yeah man what was it
Daylight the dollar store
I swear to God man yeah well it was it
was a great show the crowd was crazy
crazy crazy crowd and uh yeah I'll never
forget it we'll see hopefully maybe one
day we're there again they would have
seen me weeping
multiple times throughout the movie
throughout the Elvis movie throughout
the Elvis movie when the end of this
thing hit
I was crying so much that when the
lights came on for the credits I ran
like I had to go to the bathroom it was
[ __ ] I had to go into the bathroom
and finish crying because I didn't want
my parents to see me crying because I
was so embarrassed
I came out of the bathroom
I'm trying to like make it my eyes not
look red my mom was like oh my God I
loved it so much the ending I almost
start crying again I walk away
for two days after I got back together
so what was so emotional I'm gonna ruin
the ending for you got to see it okay
well I know he does
you foolish child
you foolish cheap joke child foolish
Hearts you just hear me you don't
deserve to hear the ending of this movie
yeah I don't know I I hate your quilts
my mom made those God sorry Mr Rosa
I mean but we know toasted bread does
not make a hot sandwich it's right well
you can't touch it if you can't pick it
up because it's hot it's got to be
melted it's got to be hot you gotta heat
the meat up you gotta what are you
talking about a toasted sandwich is hot
that's not true wow you could put ice
cold Tuna on a toast on toast it's not a
hot sandwich it's hot cold
that makes it a cold sandwich either
yeah that's what I said at the beginning
let's just take these these
in-betweeners off the table nobody
listened to me now put your mind that's
like saying a Cheesesteak Hoagie counts
as a hot sandwich it does not she does
not a cheesecake is hot a Cheesesteak
Hoagie I said the [ __ ] it's a cheese
steak made like a hoagie it's hot it's
half cold half hot
daddy
mental patience
I love McDonald's
I'm not kidding to be the worst item in
all of fast food it is it has no place
not just on their menu it is no place in
fast food yeah you think you're better
than the filet of fish 100 I am better
nothing on the McDonald's menu has a bun
as perfect as the filet fish but does it
have its own bun it is a soft bun it's a
cheeseburger if they sold those buns
on Fridays in Lent when my mom didn't
feel like cooking we got fish sticks and
that [ __ ] thing reminds me of those
awful fish sticks well it sounds like
you have an issue with your mother not
McDonald's yeah that's what it is yeah
yeah and I don't like this sandwich it's
childhood trauma that you're blaming on
McDonald's
starting to get salty you can fast all
you want your body will always suck
stand up that way
oh my God it hurts it was when I was
getting the results of my health stuff
back and I was like look I got to make
some changes one thing is I go you know
I got to get my stress levels down and
and Chris wrote back he goes oh my God
you're gonna drop dead yelling at
Skittles with a man who's afraid of
pointy pillows you are sworn
I'm afraid of pointy pills dude points
points it made me laugh or I'm dead
serious for 20 [ __ ] minutes I was
like cackling my house I'll tell you
what else what else has been making you
laugh the fact that Tom yes
loves the filet of fish yes
yes which brings us we're here to talk
which brings us to what we're here for
today Tom has come cross country to just
for this just for this yes I'm going
right back to the airport yeah he's
Thomas come from the airport and his car
waiting to go to the airport he loves
the filet-o fish so much he wants to
drop in and defend it to the Dutch this
is today's episode which is filet of
fish yay or nay or the way we worded it
was filet or fish oh yeah or kill me yes
Joe you hate the filet of fish I hate to
fillet fish my love at McDonald's is no
secret on this program we've talked
about it obviously very formal I know I
like to once I like program break out a
little class okay uh we you know
obviously we don't need to get into my
love of McDonald's by the way Happy Meal
adult toys some of them are selling for
three hundred thousand dollars on eBay
and I didn't go and get one of these
things
adult toys the adult happy meals that
just came out yeah why are they selling
for 300 because I guess there's like
rare ones that I guess that one maybe
was her hard to get or something I don't
know that's worth three hundred thousand
dollars it says some of them are selling
for upwards of 300 nobody's buying
somebody's trying to sell them for 300
it has to be the way that has to be what
it's like when you go on eBay and you
see just like something that's worth
eight dollars and somebody's selling it
for like five thousand dollars hoping
that like some like some like Chic but
it needs it that day or something are
these for money is no objects I never
went and got anything it's Chic priced
yeah yeah I'll give you Chic pricing on
that show yeah yeah I never went and got
any of these uh I should have but I
didn't uh because why do they all have
what are they all drop acid
I don't get the double eyes I didn't
like the art style of the toys which is
why I didn't I actually like that a
little bit it's a little it's not I get
it it's not McDonald's to me it doesn't
say fun but why is that an adult toy is
it does it vibrate no it's just what it
is
they just did adult I don't know I don't
know I got it honestly what is an adult
Happy Meal does anyone it's just a big
box that is a full-size meal in it and
one of those toys that's why I didn't go
get these because the ba nothing about
it was fun it just looked like cardboard
I totally doesn't have like wine in it
or something yeah anyway all right I
love McDonald's we've discussed see
there they are it's just a box and it's
like I don't know it's not that do you
guys want to go get adult Happy Meals
after this I can't because yes I do okay
you know
um
we I love McDonald's he finds a way to
bring it up in every episode so Filet O
Fish I'm not kidding to be the worst
item in all of fast food
it is it has no place not just on their
menu it is no place in fast food it has
no place in fast food nobody wants the
the so all right let's start the battle
ready so Sal's going to moderate here's
how I feel about the fish sometimes I
like it sometimes I don't I I think in
the the idea of the filet of fish I
think is
okay
sometimes though you'd look at it and be
like that's not good but I will tell you
without the tartar sauce I'll eat that
it's like a fish stick I grew up on fish
sticks yeah yeah and I I the idea of a
fish stick sounds gross but I ate them
and I like them and the idea of that
sounds gross but you throw a slice of
American cheese on it and it's a fish
stick I gotta be in the mood for the
tartar sauce take out the tartar sauce
I'm a fan put it on I'm not so I can go
both ways so what I'm gonna do here is
I'm gonna moderate okay all right let's
start to battle ready yes
b-a-t-t-l-e buds no chance today between
me and you because this is between me
and Tom okay Tom yeah I gotta say
everything Sal just said I disagree with
the only way I would conceivably like
this is on a bun with tartar sauce
without the cheese
fish head and cheese have no business
ever going together in my opinion shrimp
farm
oh disgusting I heard your little BLT
conversation all right it's not a hot
sandwich that's what I eat that's right
bacon is hot yeah that's the main part
of the sandwich no there's lettuce
tomato and Mayo flipped as soon as I
said
he flipped if I gave you a BLT without
the bacon what would you do I'd still
eat it if I gave you a sandwich with
just bacon would you be happy would you
be happy answer the question would you
be happy with the bacon yes then shut up
it's the main thing but the bacon is
if you have lettuce and tomato we're
talking a [ __ ] sandwich no offense
vegetarians I know you like that [ __ ]
but it's bacon Bacon's the god
that's it and you're fat too I know I
put on weight someone asked the other
night if I had two cups and four
sandwiches but they're good get one well
I need to eat later
the uh anyway this has been taste buds
everybody
I don't like your socks
you don't like his socks either he
doesn't have socks I stole them this is
too short too
uh uh listen Ian's input is valuable and
I think it's fair that we take it a
turkey club is a cold sandwich takeaway
you can get these days yeah you'll take
yeah
first of all right when he was like I'll
take both of you [ __ ] on myself I got
it then he's got to get reinfo I
guarantee texted this son of a [ __ ] and
I need your help over here I am an
unbiased voice no you're bi yeah I put
the Buy in bias you're a hundred percent
no listen to me
I will tell you where cold sandwiches
take the cake I will tell you where they
take the cake everything you're saying
is fine and dandy until you're at home
and you got to make it yourself nothing
beats what the [ __ ] makes a sandwich at
home oh come on you don't make
sandwiches and you're the cooker guy
neither do you you came down here to get
three of them but I'm not known for
you when you gotta go to the fridge for
lunch when you gotta when you gotta go
to the fridge for lunch or you getting
late and you don't feel like cooking and
you go to the fridge
[ __ ] that sandwich is the move and you
know it you know why you know why you
know why do you know why again back to
my friend's Point you're poor you don't
have the money if you're a meal you
think you think [ __ ] eat Elon Musk is
going making a ham sandwich for lunch no
he's getting whatever he's getting a
chicken Palm delivered to [ __ ] the
Tesla Factory hey and he's what he is
not poor he threw a pig roast here for
his birthday and made everyone pay that
is a sign of a good businessman
you made everybody pay yes for your
birthday talking to my birthday pink
rose by the way bring a song we gave
listen a sawbuck yeah yeah hold on let
me be clear about something
I didn't pay yeah let me be clear by the
way we know
yeah let me clear about something we
gave a shitload we gave a shitload of
free drinks away it's not my fault he
has a terrible [ __ ] problem and
couldn't enjoy any of the whiskey that
was seven and a half years sober and
guess what that saved me money
for more sandwiches yeah there you go
there you go seven and a half years
[ __ ] sober this kid he couldn't enjoy
any of the free [ __ ] we gave away since
when he gave away free sandwiches at a
[ __ ] birthday party give away free
drinks have you ever been to a birthday
party and they're like hey there's Pizza
have you ever been to a business yeah
you can't call it a birthday party and a
business I did it thank you
you throw yourself you're the only guy I
know that throws his own birthday
parties did I throw a birthday party I
said we're roasted a pig at Joey roses
and yeah everybody we showed up and you
had an apple in your mouth
[Laughter]
salmon versus pork chops Chris hates
pork chops with a passion dude what's
wrong with him and I said what do you
want to defend against pork chops I said
I said take a healthy meat like turkey
he goes I hate turkey disgusting he
thinks turkey who think listen I've
heard of people being like ah turkey's
boring I don't care who thinks turkey is
disgusting I used to eat turkey all the
time until Where I Live Now on Staten
Island there's wild turkeys everywhere
everywhere and I watch them walk around
Lawns and eat deer [ __ ] all [ __ ] day
and they're disgusting and once you see
an animal dude they opened they went
through the garbage the other day and
they opened up my daughters my
one-year-old daughter's diapers and ate
her [ __ ] out of the diapers and just
left them open and it was the turkeys
and he left them open do you think they
were gonna do close them back up yeah
have some decency and now I have to eat
you now because the pilgrims said you
tasted good [ __ ] you what how'd you find
out I was adopted yeah oh I I ever since
I was a baby I do oh you knew yeah they
never told me I mean they they told me
from so long early on I don't remember
that I always wondered if there's like a
coming out for the parents to adopt the
people is it like a I guess for some
people I just got told it seems very you
though to be like a suspicious baby yeah
on brand for you like I don't think you
know these people like right outside the
vagina
that's really funny Twinkie is on trial
here today I am in defense of the
twinkie you're probe Twinkie very much
and you guys are harsh prosecutors
pro-choice
that's true so much sugar that you don't
even taste any flavors yeah and that's
what the twin it almost numbs you to the
point that you when you're taking a bite
you're like I'm I'm not tasting it I'm
just getting diabetes I'm tasting my
insulin shutting down I don't think it's
worth the risk
I get it
Bill Clinton loves Twinkies anytime you
say Bill Clinton loves it's a problem
yeah that's a red flag yeah that that
the twinkie with the legs and arms too
yeah let's not forget that it's a great
mask well it's like I like that it has
skinny arms and legs because that's
probably what your body would
wow because I have to drink water a lot
yeah and it helps and it helps you even
the littlest bit I love doing it that's
what I love doing you put it in a get a
water bottle take that I already know I
know what you're gonna say can I say
we're gonna say please go yeah I love
this game I want to do this again
because I think that's what you do
because this is what I do what okay you
take the water bottle you put it you put
the Crystal Light in the water bottle
already but then you drink and every
time you drink a little you keep filling
up with more water or no I said it so
basically what you're doing is you're
diluting the drink as you go but you're
getting the taste of you know of it all
the way down to the end less and less
and less but you could chuck it because
it tastes really really good I like
putting it up there because everybody in
the audience is going what the [ __ ] oh
you put it in your water bottle
everybody's like what do I get to drink
and then you're out there with this
[ __ ] what flavor purple purple or
raspberry and it's this I take the the
banner off or whatever it just looks
like they're like what the [ __ ] I I
swear to every show somebody would do
what were you drinking yeah curious [ __ ]
yeah do you remember the Crystal Light
jingle from the 80s that was like jingle
tell me if this rings a bell to you
ready yeah I believe in Crystal Light
cause I believe in me yes yes that was a
[ __ ] great jingle almost as good as a
[ __ ] just
look at these people this is a late
night swim with a with a half nude
adults look how big look how big the
package used to have to be though look
at that Crystal Light Crystal Light that
was before we knew that that was just
full of aspartame right it's all white
people too this is before they allowed
any minorities in anything look at how
white if you go back and watch
commercials yeah from the 80s and
natural representation here is not one
there's not even an Italian
we're talking Puritans yeah right
Puritan yeah we're talking a little
abuses I mean look at it dude like yeah
there's not one it's all blonde chicks
it's all it was always a blonde girl
what is going on there exactly in this
Crystal Light commercial oh they just
went from an orgy and then they jumped
in the pool are they at the gym but then
all of a sudden they're night swinging
look at what you what's all that water
splashing down around her every
commercial every commercial was like the
same set as a porn set like that gym has
been used in porns that gym that they
use that gym right there that scale has
jizz on it it has to be oh it's in the
that they do commercials like in the
valley in the valley yeah in the valley
that's what can I tell you the story
yeah please I don't know if I told it on
this or hey babe but in 1995 yeah I went
to I took my first plane ride yeah okay
yeah I was like 18. I went to California
with my friends I stood there for a
couple weeks
my friend we crashed on my friend's
cousin's uh couch my friend's cousin
about 10 years older than us at the time
just signed a deal with Warner Brothers
his band was called sister whiskey and
they were rock and roll band and they
signed like a big deal with Warner
Brothers and they had a Hit Radio single
called Simple Man right okay I'm getting
to this part now no I'm interested he
had a friend yeah that was in the valley
that his job was house sitting for a
porn producer named Bruce seven who I
think has since passed God Rest his soul
right I don't know I don't know him
personally but yeah I tell Shane when
anyone passes right so so he he calls
him and says oh come visit me I'm house
sitting this guy's house in the valley
yeah it's this big beautiful house or
pool we can hang out I'm watching his
cats so we said all right so we go there
he lets us in this guy's long hair this
is when like like rock was in they were
all right
he'll be like what's up guys come on in
he's like yeah just and you walk in and
there's a a long hallway with all the
vhs's like a thousand of them he puts
the guy has him in the front hallway
when you work with us all his porn wow
all the awards wow on the shelves right
so I'm like all right this is just out
right in front as soon as you come in
the house right yeah so he's like I'm
watching his cats and he's like you know
he shows us around he's like this is the
yard oh come down here cases down the
hole he opens the door it's like a it's
a huge huge walk-in closet
all sex stuff in there right and he goes
yeah he goes open that chest we open
it's a chest maybe 100 150 dildos in it
he goes my job's to clean the dildos too
so we're like all right that's funny
right so we go out and there's a
Contraption in the living room that they
built it's like a steel Contraption with
like ropes and it's like a sex swing
right in the goddamn living room right
and we're like that's unbelievable so
they must do do porn here so he's like
watch he takes out of cassette he puts
him with sitting on the couch we're
watching and they're having sex in the
porn on the couch that was sitting here
and then they use the contraption and
everything really and then he goes wait
wait wait check this out check this out
and the Hand reaches in with a glove on
it and hands a dildo he goes that was my
hands
that was that was his mom actually I bet
he still does that by the way
[Laughter]
I know that should come from me I'm
actually a little [ __ ] uncomfortable
right now all right yeah well we went
from my son yeah sorry about that to the
kids done listen sorry about that kids
Crystal Light cause I believe in me
Jesus why is she drinking Crystal Light
in the pool
it's so refreshing it's refreshing and
you believe in yourself I I you still
does it have aspartame still they have
they have they progressed and found like
monk fruits man I don't know what I I
the aspartame dude I quit alcohol I quit
drugs I quit cigarettes I'm not eating
shitty you look
fantastic thank you very much buddy your
skin has a glow yeah I wouldn't just say
it oh thank you buddy I appreciate that
yeah there's some beautiful cat oh thank
you man it's beautiful thank you I
really they it's like you can't get more
perfect you know my mother takes full
credit for it really yeah every 20
minutes I'd roll yeah I'd roll you over
it looks
yourself uh of course McDonald's comes
into play
I don't support this video or approve of
it it says gross video shows maggots in
McDonald's sauce dispenser I don't
support this I don't approve of it you
know uh oh God I can't I can't
that's the spout that's the spot oh God
I will never use that again I will never
use that I will never ever ever ever I
use it at Wendy's they have it I'm like
oh it's fun because I can control my
ketchup and you can't tell me how much
ketchup I won't do it you know it stands
it stands for a reason that's it's like
they say don't drink out of a Buddha in
a hotel because they don't clean the
pipes yeah we don't know what's in there
in the fridge in there we don't know
what's in there
oh this is funny oh the humanities
maggots in it
I hope so I hope so
sucker I'll say this about Mayo I think
if you make your food properly you don't
need Mayo if you make your chicken
properly juicy enough you don't people
use it just Sean for fundamentals I want
to congratulate you for one of the
dumbest things
that's how bad Mayo is it's lice can't
stand the mail Mayo is a great way to
add shine to dull house plants yeah
that's a red flag
what do you say you like mail more you
see me light up no you didn't today
you're being loud for no sake what do
you mean I'm not being allowed you're
not making any good points Joe you're
just yelling into a void bro what are
you talking about it's it's getting sad
for me we need to watch you it's getting
sad you're devolving you're devolving
you're infuriating you're inferiorating
you're infuriating you're in you scream
into the void you mean you say nothing
you have not matured at all in life I
said I really want to thank you guys
look look
oh
oh my God God I wish I didn't see that
oh I wish I didn't see that it looks
like a magic guy
he's like Yo dude
I put it on my Tick Tock oh my goodness
get that big that was a Is that real
this kid's got an insane case of lice oh
my God it haunts me to this day oh I
wish I didn't see it but lice doesn't
turn into like worms like that that's
why big ones in that kid's head that kid
those things were like setting I don't
even want to keep watching it it's oh
God that is that is that's like
maggot-sized light that's insane I've
never seen that I don't think lice turn
into that though is what I'm saying I
feel like that's something else
look at these people this is a late
night swim with a with half nude adults
look how big
it's all white people too this is before
they allowed any minorities in anything
look at how white if you go back and
watch commercials yeah from the 80s and
90 representation there is not one
there's not even an Italian yeah I mean
we're talking Puritans yeah right
Puritan yeah we're talking a little
abuses what is going on there exactly in
this Crystal Light commercial oh they
just went from an orgy and then they
jumped in the pool are they at the gym
but then all of a sudden they're night
swinging look at what you what's all
that water splashing down around her
every commercial every commercial was
like the same set as a porn set like
that gym has been used in porns that gym
that they use in the Chris that gym
right there that scale has done it
I don't know if I can go out this
Halloween I'm really trying to stick to
this health thing
and go outside I cannot take you serious
right now
telling me you don't know I'm trying to
stick to this health thing you have a
processed meat head I'm just a guy
trying to cut the mustard right I got
you uh and it's been a real dog trying
to stop oh my God I got no beef ketchup
going I know I got no beef would you not
going but catch up I know and look let
us let us let us talk about all these
things why would anything in my life be
a decent case scenario it's got to be
the worst case scenario can you clip
that whole thing of him in the hot dog
head and just use that for when we need
it please please
happening today he he spells analogous
on the first try he can't spell the on
the first try oh spaghetti oh devil
that's disgusting deviled eggs are
awesome there is nothing more exciting
at a barbecue than a plate of deviled
eggs I get so excited okay I've never
been really insulted by a child I I
haven't I've been good about it because
my niece so one time I was hanging out
with my niece Madison and at the time
she was like six or something like that
right and uh we were we were playing uh
Nintendo it was it I didn't even live
here it was my old place and I was uh
like going in hard on I wasn't giving
her any leeway I was dominating and I
was such I was giving her a little taste
of the Rose
and I saw her um getting annoyed I saw
it start and uh that only made me want
to do it more because there was really
nothing she could do you know like I
think we were playing like I think we
were playing a
um uh NBA Jam oh you were outside I was
on fire yeah and uh or maybe that or was
like I don't know maybe it was Street
Fighter it was something where I was
like Hadoop it was I don't know you had
30 years of experience
and I was like what's the matter you
know whatever and then she gets up at
one point she just I saw the steam she's
six six eight remember she gets up and
she throws the remote and she goes you
know what Uncle Sal you're boring
I started laughing so hard because I was
like she had to that was what she
thought was going to get me back yeah
like she she did nothing she could do
game-wise and so she's like I have to I
had to get him back and she was looking
for a mic drop at her mic drop I'd say
she found it and I left I just kept
laughing so hard I'm like I'm boring
it's such a funny thing to say to
someone and then like later that night
when I was trying to go to sleep I was
like why would she say that
like where did she even get that like
why would you say that about me because
I'm not boring look at you asked people
about me they would not describe me as
boring so where does she get off
so the next time when she came back I
saw my whole bit really but it's true
the next time she came back to my house
I said can I talk to you in the other
room
casseroles versus salads and I will open
this argument up by saying Dan I don't
know who you think you are to come on
this show the first time ever and try to
step in the ring with me against potato
salad tuna salad egg salad macaroni
salad pasta salad coleslaw dog what are
you even thinking and we're not even
getting into the variations of each
we're just talking straight across the
board all I hear is
germs
sickness all those things you're dealing
with expound
let them let them stay out too long and
what happens well what kind of animals
leave an amount everyone yeah everyone
no one properly takes care of a salad a
potato salad a macaroni salad you go to
a barbecue that thing's been outside for
three hours right so you're getting it's
got a spoiled mayonnaise it's got a
shelf life it does it's got a quick
shelf life that's got a very quick show
those good things do no it's not it's a
hot strip most Pleasures are Fleet
stripper it's heading right to disaster
be more like them and change the secret
formula to cop
and guess what and tapped out
immediately when everybody said this
sucks and tap that immediately where
everybody says this sucks you're gonna
throw you're gonna put game caplet in my
face
[Music]
welcome back Connor do not speak bad of
him he was an icon in the late 70s
[Music]
I was getting a massage once on the up
and up and uh at the end of it the woman
leaned in she she was Asian woman but it
was at it wasn't like anything you know
bad it was a professional place and she
leaned in it was like the 57th minute
and I was on my back and she leaned in
and right she was right here I heard her
whisper and she goes
for 57 minutes and I just turned around
I had to do I turned around and looked
and I went no
no because that would be ridiculous
it's his son
it's his child and I put my head back in
the thing and started laughing she's
like he has a 15 year old boy inside so
funny the left Jaden is 15 the right's
21. all right folks here we go Humble
Pie who won in second place with 41 is
prosciutto what
[Laughter]
that's perfect that's perfect oh yeah
the people have spoken back to Italy
back with you to Italy get on your
mortadell boats and get the [ __ ] out you
just have to you just have to say I
still love you
I still love you Joe I love you too all
right folks I still love you babe I love
you too I missed I forgot I still love
you back I still love you babe we love
you too
all right I still love you baby
I still love you you guys are both okay
congrats to you babe thanks buddy I
still love you I love you too
I still love you babe the episodes
they come into the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two Fool's gonna fight but
only one food can be right taste buds
man yeah they're coming to the mic I'm
talking taste buds